some [ __ ] are always trying to
ice skate uphill hey it's been a little
while since I've talked about ways to
integrate things into the MCU that
either might or in this case we know are
going to happen I've done a couple of
times before and I enjoy but I don't
always think that I have much to say but
this time we're gonna talk about blade
and we know blade is coming because they
have officially announced Maher slow Ali
as playing blade which first off awesome
casting I approve love that and then the
question becomes well how do we get him
into the mix now first thing that can be
acknowledged is that honestly if they
wanted to they don't have to really
properly integrate him into the rest of
the MCU at all they can basically leave
him in isolation doing his own thing
with his own vibe which is totally
viable however given that the MCU does
try to go for a uniformity of sort of
age appropriateness and a consistency of
the universe there are still a couple of
hitches that need to be dealt with or at
least adjusted for versus what we're
used to seeing from blade as far as the
character is himself is concerned yet no
real alterations need to happen here his
origin his powers how he works what he
does
he fights vampires cool the thing that
they're gonna have to be careful about
what they do and how they do it is the
vampires the thing that he hunts so the
MCU is in an interesting place it's
certainly at this point varied enough
that they do not have to justify where
vampires came from there's vampires cool
add it to the pile along with everything
else but a little bit like when they
eventually get her onto the x-men in
injured
mutants they do kinda have to address
why hasn't this come up before now I've
talked about how to handle that with
mutants and I think even a couple of
videos up to this point um like from a
while back but I have talked about that
and the vampires well somewhat different
it's a little bit of the same thing at
least in regards to how they're usually
depicted in stories that involve blade
because blade doesn't usually go after
just any old vampires he goes after the
head honchos he goes after people like
Dracula he goes after the people who are
running the shadowy organizations behind
governments and things like that and
that is the angle that's actually gonna
be a bit tricky to integrate it into the
MCU because we already had some way that
it was called Hydra like how many secret
shadow puppeteering running the world
things are they're going to how many how
many layers are in this onion you know
there's only so many times you can pull
that so what we have is we have a
situation where we have a character can
basically be imported as is he won't be
able to swear as much as he did under
Wesley Snipes which is a shame but on
that he imports cleanly and his enemy
roster as a concept as far as what they
are that imports cleanly but it's the
nature of what he's fighting against
blade especially in adaptations that
we've seen up to this point being the
Wesley Snipes movies and the short-lived
TV show have always been about him going
up against something bigger than him
something with more members better
resources you know a society of vampires
that has resources and establishments
and and is pretty well integrated into
society secretly now on the one hand you
might think to yourself well if they're
secret what's the problem so we haven't
seen it up to this point because it's a
secret sort of world and yeah I think
it's yeah some leeway not a ton though
not in terms of the you know they
control the blood banks
kind of thing which is again what blade
has traditionally sort of the angle that
they've gone for making it believable
that vampires have been that integral
behind the scenes and that has never
come up or been hinted at that might be
a little tough to swallow not impossible
you could do it but honestly I think
it's an opportunity to just go a
different direction and to distinguish
this take on blade a bit more because I
don't think the character needs a
massive rework I think honestly Wesley
Snipes nailed it before I don't expect
her so at least to be vastly different
I'm sure he'll bring his own flavor he's
an excellent actor I have no doubt about
that whatsoever but I do think that you
can put him in a setting in a world that
can feel distinctly different and it
already will because it's part of the
MCU
but even as setting aside that bigger
context just the fact that importing how
that worked over here doesn't map on
cleanly again doable that's a reason to
just try something else and there's a
number of options you could have blade
be well a bit more of a hunter you could
really play that up where instead of
being the underdog taking on the massive
resources of vampire society he's a
hunter wiping out the stragglers that
anger would work especially well if you
wanted to have an audience POV character
I you know sort of someone who is caught
up in all this but doesn't know what's
going on because that would give them a
nicely conflicted view of blade like
okay well these things they seem like
they're monsters but you're just trying
to wipe them out and they just seem to
be desperately trying to survive like we
actually okay with this and whether or
not you actually want to play with that
morality
or just use it to make blade himself a
play up the anti-hero angle of him a
little bit more you can decide how much
you want to weigh that but that would be
certainly an option the other thing
would be to just not have him focus
exclusively on vampires what you could
do to honor his roots you could have him
you know taking on basically any kind of
creature of the night you feel like it
could be werewolves banshees ghosts
original demons sort of things basically
the cab Monster has of Castlevania you
can have him take him on that and have a
vampire heading that up so that it's
still gonna come down to blade taking on
a vampire because at the very least the
first movie or season of a show I can't
remember if they've confirmed if he's
getting a show or a movie wherever he
appears the first thing should end with
him fighting a vampire because it needs
to bring out that him fighting his own
nature as a half vampire and the best
way to do that is have him confronting
someone who is fully that so I think you
will still need to do that but there's
no reason that he has to be mowing down
nothing but vampires in order to get
there again to fully comparison to
Castlevania there is a ton of gothic
monstrous creatures that you can pull
from to have him work his way through
until he gets to the vampire so that's
another option I think in general
there's just a chance for it to get a
little bit more down and dirty because
you look at the blade movies and the
first one had a very sort of high-tech
Sheen to it almost like a techno vibe a
little bit at times and then the second
one being Garen will Deltora was a
little bit moody or a little bit more
gothic but I think you could get really
legitimately gritty you'll notice I
skipped talking about blade Trinity
because I watched it once I don't want
to watch it again
I prefer not to think about it but you
could get you could really emphasize the
fact that blade is hunting in sewers he
is tracking
these things down through back alleys he
is really backing them into a corner and
the core is that they're backed into are
not nice places which also makes him not
a nice guy badass sure having be the
badass but let's make blade feel
dangerous and that's just sort of my
general thoughts about ways and things
to both watch out for and opportunities
to play with not only blade but the
world and the character in which he
operates when they get around to getting
him into the MCU those are my thoughts
what do you think about anything I've
said or what ideas do you have to
contribute to this whatever they are
drop something on down in the comments
let's talk about it you know all the
stuff to do like share subscribe there's
a patreon etc etc don't worry about it
though you don't have to do any of it
because at the end of the day you are
the council I just run the meetings and
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]